[Music]
so
[Music]
so
[Music]
so
yo
what is going on everybody happy
saturday good morning good evening
good afternoon wherever you all are
watching from around the world
i am very excited because today we are
once again using unreal engine to create
a photo reel environment we're going to
do it in one sitting as quick as
possible from start to finish from
beginning to end
from
scratch
to full completion
right we're doing it together
i got links in the description if you
guys want to download unreal engine 5 if
you want to join me and do this along
with me it's pretty much all free um
so
i it took me long enough to learn this
program
and it's about time that i
as i'm as i'm starting to understand it
starting to get it show you guys
everything you need to know in one
sitting to do this right um let me show
you what we're gonna be making
all right so we are in unreal engine
we can fly around
and
make this scene here
super fun
all right it's gonna be awesome looks
pretty darn photo reel we got some rain
coming up in here too little drip drops
from the sky
um and this is actually not as bad
as it looks
um
so
i'm ready to hop into this thing
it's gonna be great
but before we do you all know how it is
we got a sponsor today so let's hear
from them and we will be back
in about a minute and a half and we're
gonna get started on this scene see you
guys soon
sponsored by manscaped
oh y'all
bring it in
first off bathe
regularly
second if you're dealing with
this situation up here with the same
razor you're dealing with
down there
don't
cut the nonsense this is the performance
package 4.0 by manscaped and it's got
everything you need to keep things in
tip-top shape the lawnmower 4.0 is easy
to use because it's wireless and
waterproof and these little ball guards
it comes with will def
oh man
will definitely come in handy
and just like we use aftershave or some
sort of beard oil for our face the
performance package 4.0 comes with their
crop preserver and crop reviver keep
things fresh throughout the day also
included in the performance package is
the weed whacker because at a certain
point ear and nose hair is a thing but
you gotta be vigilant so for a limited
time this performance package ships with
two extra gifts these anti-chafing
boxers and this nifty little travel bag
so have some self-respect and use the
code punisher to get 20 off plus free
shipping anything you need at
manscape.com by clicking that link in
the description
and don't forget to bathe
that's right y'all
bathing is very important
don't forget to bathe
and we're all sitting at our desks
getting all oily collecting dust it's
nasty
um
but thank you y'all thank you all gotta
gotta
gotta make a living right gotta pay them
bills so i appreciate you all listening
if you all interested you know that link
is up in that description but without
further ado
it is time to get this art
uh let's see let's switch it up
all right
so
yes i already made the art you're like
what how did he already make it yes
because i need a thumbnail that looks
good
also
i need to make this thing in order to
know
how to
you know
make it again super efficiently that's
how i waste time
is by doing it the first time on the
stream nah i do it first time during the
week son
and then
we restart so that's exactly what i'm
gonna do i'm gonna restart this dang
thing make a new level and we're
starting from scratch like i said
uh file new level
just gonna go basic here create this
thing
and we are gonna build that whole thing
from scratch
live on the stream all right so let's
first off save right you got to save
sewer
stream
bam all right so
let's talk about the idea first off um
cause i didn't just pull this out of my
head this is uh if you guys want to
create your own stuff here in the future
you know you gotta use reference so i
use a program called pureref
and let me load up
this goodness here all right so
this is a real place all right i was in
newfoundland
as you all know
uh
maybe at this point
i love newfoundland i went there with my
buddy adam who made the music at the
beginning of this stream
we went there together to find fog lots
of fog
um
and we also found a lot of abandoned
spots just like this
and i climbed down this
dang sewer hole right here and climbed
all the way down in here and got this
picture it was awesome freaking such a
cool spot
you know a little bit more detail
close-ups
detail close-ups so i'm using this as
reference originally i had a bunch of
other references all
shots that i took
throughout my life
at abandoned places i love me some
abandoned spots this one's from
thomaston georgia this is the mill it's
no longer there this is our boy brett
skate
brett driver
also
taken at this mill
um
you know we used to do a lot of short
films together military type short films
this is a paint factory in atlanta
flooded floor
i love the detail and the texture up in
here the lighting is incredible and
originally i was going to create this
scene first but
i ended up going with the newfoundland
one this is more like hotel stuff and
thomaston you know y'all you guys saw
this one already this is in canton
georgia these are all torn down at this
point
um this is the prison
abandoned uh burnt down prison
in atlanta
that one's pretty tough to get into
same deal the burnt down prison
prison
this is in la
yeah lots of cool stuff i love me some
abandoned stuff um but i decided to go
with this so this was the the
inspiration the recreation for our scene
today so that was taking um
guiding a lot of my decisions so i'm
gonna actually just kind of dock this
down here for us
so we can constantly kind of
check back in and see what's good with
it
where can we put this guy
where should we put this guy
i don't know this is fine for now
um
the first thing i want to do you know i
put out that video two weeks ago talking
about the forest door scene right so
the first thing i want to do is block
this scene out as quickly as possible so
what i did in c4d
is i made a
let's see where are you at meshes
sewer
geometry yes i made this in c4d
right
just a little uh
cylinder extruded with the top cut out
there's a little square cut out from the
top
pretty simple
right and
unreal is just looking good already this
is this is good news it's dark in here
that's how we want it to look
we got the sun is going to shine down
from here so yeah very basic you all can
do this in blender you can do this in
c4d this is super super easy stuff a
cylinder with a little roof piece
um
right that pops right off
so
let's go ahead and grab a character just
so we can like get a sense of scale here
also it's really dark in here
so
i just want to drop a little white solid
on here bounce some light around
just so we can kind of see what's going
on
and
let's do
oh cryo oh my god
oh my goodness cryo chambers up in here
yo
wow that's that's deep you all don't
even realize um so cryochamber is a
label that does a lot of ambient dark
ambient stuff
and i started listening i think it
there's an artist his name is lustmord
it's a ridiculous name
i think that's his label
i remember as a kid listening to his
music as i go to sleep and it's like
jail cell doors closing in chains in the
night like really stuff you're not
really supposed to go to sleep to
but um i love ambient music dark ambient
music in cryo chamber
um
mount shrine who is my favorite ambient
artist of all time
it was on their label uh rest in peace
caesar
never forget
um but that's cool
that's cool that crowd chambers here
that's amazing all right so
um
let's see let's see let's grab a person
i went to
the
epic library the marketplace
and i just grabbed a mannequin
from here just any free character that
way i can actually
see and get a sense of scale
because that is very important where are
you here we are
bam
we got our
meshes mannequin
character mesh
yeah this is fine
pretty good pretty good scale you know i
built it in c40
uh to actually match the scale here so
okay let's um let's make a camera right
so i'm going to up in the place actors
window again if you're not seeing this
you can go to window place actors and
let's just grab like a
cindy camera actor drag it into the
scene right click it
pilot it and now we're in i'm holding
right click and navigating with w a s
and d
look at my bearings here
pretty sweet it's a little too punched
in for me so i'm gonna grab that
in the outliner
and let's just change the
focal length to something like i think i
had it at like a 12 or something
right to get the most bang
for our buck here that looks pretty good
to me
yeah that's super solid
okay so we got our camera angle right um
let's we can always we'll tweak the
stuff later but this is about all we
need for now camera wise let's go ahead
and set up our lighting because that's a
big big part of what we're doing here
you know we want the lighting to look as
good as possible
and then we can start adding all the
stuff into our scene with a better idea
of how it's all going to look in the end
um
all right
so
[Music]
we have our directional light this is
our sun without this we don't see
anything okay
and it's kind of confusing there's a lot
of stuff there's like well there's
height fog and then there's the
atmosphere and then there's the skylight
and then there's the sky sphere and then
there's the volumetric clouds it's a lot
right
it's a lot and that's why unreal is so
darn confusing for me let's start with
one at a time directional light and this
all comes built in when you start your
your blank level all right
but let's just go ahead and orient this
thing um
we can see it here
if you hit control
back tick that's the button next to
number one
on your keyboard we can kinda
we can orient this between world and
local orientation but
let's go here
boom we want it
bam just like that
shining straight down into
this well
or this reservoir
beautiful we got that bounce light lumen
is doing its thing it's looking really
really nice
um dimensions of the cylinder man i
can't really tell you
just know that a person is this big
that's about it i'm just going off the
eye here i'm not trying to take
measuring tapes out or anything
it's just what looks good you know
um
it's about three person three people
tall i'd say
yeah
all right um from here
we
want to kind of go for that uh
this cone of light that we're seeing
here in this reference
so we could do a number of things
to get that right we have our
exponential height fog which we can
scroll down and turn on volumetric fog
and we can
take the density up
and you can start to see some light rays
coming in here which is pretty sweet if
we go to our directional light we can
take our volumetric scattering intensity
up and it's gonna really
spotlight it which is super cool but
it's actually not
what i'm really going for
um i want more of an like an overcast
ambient light coming up from the top so
i'm gonna take this back down
um we can reset this we can always add
that stuff later right
what i'm gonna do to punch this up um
you know we could take the directional
light we could take the source angle and
just take it to like 30 and we're going
to get some weird artifacts here on the
side we'll get into fixing that
um in a second but that's gonna soften
up
your sunlight
right just a little bit
but what i really want to do is kind of
just do this with a area light so i'm
gonna go to my lights in place actor
let's grab a wreck light
boom
space bar
to toggle between position rotation and
scale i'm gonna make sure that this is
checked up here so we snap
on the angles 90 degrees
we're gonna just come right outside here
and bam something like this
is kind of what
we're going for right
um
let's first make sure
the direct light the attenuation radius
right that's just we want to make sure
it's kind of maxed out
not kind of max we want to make sure
it's maxed out
it basically is like how far does the
light travel it's gonna travel the full
the full distance
um
and if we move this forward and
backwards we can kind of see what it's
doing
now a bigger light will have softer
shadows
i'm going to move this up
yup that looks nice
and i'm going to make it larger so the
wreck light
source width and source height let's
just take that to like 512 by 512
even 1024
by 10 24.
cool
and we're gonna work all of this stuff
in for sure but like we're starting to
get to a point now where like
it's looking decent we'll come back and
tweak it
but let's take the intensity up
and we can start filling this scene out
with
all the good stuff all the meat
that makes up this uh this well
and then we'll come back we'll start
solving these issues up here
um with the light leak and stuff
because that happens with lumen
apparently if your walls aren't thick
enough the light will leak through them
so
when i made this
cylinder
i made sure to give it thickness
right but we're still getting a little
bit of light leak so we'll have to
figure something out on that end
let's just talk about the last little
bits of light here
we took off the sky atmosphere we can
bring that back in
we can really bring all these things
back in
the volumetric clouds you probably don't
need i'm just going to delete them
because we're inside
sweet g will uh hide show and hide all
of your different icons here
okay
so um
let's talk about materials let's get
some base materials on this guy the
reason i separated the top
from the bottom
from the actual core of this thing is so
i can give them different materials
so
i have a material pack
called endless concrete
and
it was because i needed really long
strips of concrete for my alternate
realities render last year
um so i made this whole pack
of really long bits of concrete
um
it's on my gum road if you all want to
check it out
but you don't need it you can you can
definitely go up here you can go kwixel
bridge
and you can
pull any this all comes free with unreal
engine it's the coolest thing go to
surfaces and we can go to concrete
and you can start pulling from the from
these different concrete bits like cast
in c2 i guess is how it's pronounced
which technically is like
see look at that
you can see all the different slabs and
everything in the concrete lots of
detail there
um
so that would be c2 cass and c2 and you
can kind of go through this and
pull different ones i'll show you how
you can bring something over
[Music]
like let's say you want this one right
bam
man this is like super laggy when you're
in unreal
so you click on it
and you can choose highest quality which
is usually 8k high quality is 4k medium
quality is 2k generally right um so
you'd be fine with with high or medium
quality
you're going to download it once it's
downloaded you'll hit add and it will
appear in your
in your scene here
under
where is it under mega scans material or
surfaces
boom right so you can just like
drop these different things on but you
notice how it changed the light so much
right it's much darker now because we're
not bouncing this white light all around
but that's okay we're gonna get there
so i'm gonna use my
concrete pack
and i'm gonna pull i believe
wall
one
boom
yeah that looks freaking great um
let's
handle this uh
auto
auto exposure business because you see
how it's dark in here and then it's like
oh my gosh and then it gets all
should be
come on now there
is there autofocus i can't i can't tell
if there's auto exposure going on anyway
uh what you want to do
if you have auto exposure going on
so we have our camera right let's go
ahead and pop this in a folder
and i'm gonna actually let's drag our
lighting up in here
all this other stuff we can pop into a
folder called geo
awesome awesome so the cine camera actor
if you type brightness
in the details panel
and you check both min and max
here we go now here we go now there's
our auto focus
what we can do
is we can choose
our own right so if you set them both to
the same number there's not going to be
any sort of autofocus
but i liked it a little brighter like
that i think just to see what's going on
we can set it to like
negative five
that's actually pretty intense um
negative four this is fine
just for us to like
see what's going on here
um
okay so this wall right this material
if we double click it
right we can get all of these different
attributes
and adjust them right so we can adjust
the normal intensity roughness blah blah
blah but what i want to do is adjust the
offset x and y offset
to make sure that this is
really fitting our scene
and going for the best look here
[Music]
heck yeah
that is
fantastic
fantastic sweet all right um the ceiling
too let's do the ceiling i have some
ceiling materials ceiling ones ceiling
two ceiling three let's drop that on
there
that looks awesome this is actually the
underside of a bridge
and the floor is actually going to be
water because if we look at
the reference
it's flooded you can see the reflection
on the ground it's just a bunch of crap
on
a little bit of water
so
what i'll do is grab a plane or even a
wall let's see
[Music]
let's try plane
drag it out
bring it up just a touch
and let's
adjust
its scale
10 by 10 by 10.
let's go 15 just to make sure
boom
sweet and i'm gonna make a material
i'll show you guys how i made this
material it's already been made but i'll
make it again for y'all
um i try to organize all my stuff right
materials we got our materials and we
got all of our different stuff in here
you want to be as organized as possible
it's really going to help you
you know stay organized it's pretty
obvious okay i'm going to right click
and i'm going to make a material boom
i'm gonna call this
master material
underscore
uh
water
tutorial
bam
i'm gonna go up in here
and
i'm cheating it i'm not doing actual
water i'm just gonna make it reflective
in chrome right
uh cheat when you can
so it needs a base color you can right
click it promote it to parameter
and that's gonna make a i think it's a
three vector
oh that's oh shoot
wait what
i don't know why that's not working
anyway i'm gonna right click and promote
metallic to a parameter
and i'm gonna do specular
and i believe that is everything we need
we can also do roughness but
probably not gonna need it by default
roughness is zero
specular we're gonna go one we want it
to be shiny
metallic we want to chrome this thing
out
we'll set it to one and then the base
color i believe needs to be set to white
and then that should be a chrome ball
bone
sweet
so i'm gonna save this
from here i'm gonna right click this
master material create material instance
and the material instance is what we'll
put on the floor
boom sun
now we have
janky reflections right that's because
lumen is probably using screen space
reflection but it's okay
because we're going to be viewing our
stuff from here we're going to be
viewing our stuff from here we might be
viewing our stuff from here like you saw
in this tutorial
right at the beginning of this thing
but
this some of this stuff will be covered
up we can also i'm wondering if we can
[Music]
why is it not bouncing the ceiling i
wonder
let's
make
a post
process volume
drag it into our scene
hit g it's going to show and hide all of
our stuff
and
for this post process process volume to
take effect
it's only going to take effect inside
this box
and think of the post process volume as
ways to
crank render settings ways to add color
correction
ways to add lens effects etc all that's
just gonna happen in that box unless we
set it
to unbound
bam now it's happening everywhere
um
so i wonder if it's like a
it's definitely if here's here here's
where i've run into a problem okay
if i type reflection
all right we have our reflections we
have our lumen reflections of screams
space reflections et cetera et cetera
ray trace reflections
we are using lumen for our reflections
if i switch to
to uh
to retraced
we're getting crisper reflections but
it's doing a weird thing where it's like
making it way brighter on the ground
than it needs to be
i don't know why
it might have something to do with the
global illumination
i i don't know i do not have the answer
for this maybe this is a william foche
situation here um
william where are you at
um
but
i'm just doing lumen because it just
looks so darn good we are getting a
little some blurry reflections but
whatever
once we add all of our stuff into the
scene it's gonna look freaking awesome
and it's not even gonna be a worry
um but i wonder if i can like i think
it's
so this is screen space reflection
and that's no good
lumen is fine we can go to lumen
reflection quality and ray lighting mode
so we can maybe change it from
hit lighting for reflections i think hit
lighting for reflections is
oh weird it's taking out
if i take the quality of this up to four
it's not really doing anything
this looks the best to me i know there's
a setting i should be using but i'm good
for now right
um we can't get hung up on the details
we need to keep moving forward
so i'm going to move post process volume
into the camera folder i'll move this
plane into the geo folder
and we are all organized our lighting is
generally set up we have some textures
popping off here
um
i think it's time to start building out
these columns and painting all of this
grungy nastiness on the floor
and then we'll get into the graffiti
adding all that good stuff
tweaking tweaking tweaking so
let's go ahead and add those columns
because they are the next biggest piece
of this whole thing so
uh once again what i did i went to the
top left here
and i went to quicksole bridge
and what i do when i start a new project
is usually i do this in the standalone
bridge because
qixel bridge version is a little laggy
i'll go and essentially look for 3d
assets or
or materials
anything that is going to fit my scene
and i'm going to go through and i'm
going to give it a little heart right
here i'm going to favorite
the the asset
so that i build up
all of these favorites here and i can
just batch download them and batch add
them to the scene right
so what i did is i pulled
some of these
concrete columns
right
i'll click on them
let's find one that's already downloaded
this one i already downloaded it and you
want to do the nanite mesh
um it's just going to help with
performance you're going to be able to
glide through your scene easily quickly
without bogging down your frame rate so
just make sure you choose nanite and add
it to your scene right but i already i
already did all this stuff okay
so it's going to show up in your mega
scans folder and your 3d assets
and we should have cement
oh here's another thing i do by the way
guys i'm gonna save this
and i'm gonna go into
the assets i made a new level
um
of all the assets that i would use
in this scene
so i literally just went file new level
blank or basic right here
and i just drag these different assets
right
from the content browser
into
a level where i can actually see
everything that's going on
that way i'm able to choose oh i know i
want this one i want that one i want
that one it just helps give me a good
overview of what i'm working with
right this was for another idea
um but this guy this is this is what
we're using so
let me go back
to the
sewer
stream bam
and we should uh it's all dark now
because we're not piloting this camera
for some reason if you right click and
you can't pilot your camera you're going
to have to just kind of navigate see
your camera here right click the
physical camera and pilot it that way
um
so let's pull that concrete pillar
boom
right here
yep yep
and i'm going to hold alt and just
duplicate it on top of itself as opposed
to stretching it out
and we can select all these by holding
shift
ctrl g will group them and then we can
hold alt and move them over as well and
of course
we will rotate it
so it doesn't look exactly the same
i'm holding spacebar to cycle between my
gizmos
boom yeah that's looking pretty sweet
bam all right all right all right so
we're getting there right we're getting
there it's looking pretty sweet
so
from here
[Music]
let's let's go ahead and add that ladder
so uh in the reference
right there's a ladder it's kind of like
the whole thing it's the light with the
ladder
and that would probably be the next most
defining
part of
this scene here
so in c4d you all can use blender
whatever you want um
i modeled a little ladder here let's
pull that up mesh ladder
ladder boom
bing bong
i'm hit f
it's gonna
snap me to the thing i have selected
let's pull it out
switch it on around
180 bam
if you aren't snapping if your angles
aren't snapping that's going to be this
little toggle right here you have
position snap
rotation snap scale snap
again hitting spacebar to cycle between
all my gizmos and i'm just going to get
it into the wall here
and move it up
appropriately
boom
and i think i'm gonna scale
this ladder up a bit
um because i really i want you to be
able to see the ladder right
let's just make it two times bigger
yeah
that feels pretty
kind of big uh 1.75
cool
not really worried about the
yeah that's that's
that's mighty fine and
let's get a material on it again this is
just a bridge material
for that y'all can get for free
so let's find it mega scans where you at
surface
boom
tar stained concrete now shuttered
concrete rusty metal sheet that's what
i'm talking about bam
we got our rusty metal sheet material
right on here
it's not too shabby
it's going to be so far away like
you're not going to be able to tell but
it's better than just base gray
ooh we got a little problem
control g will
hopefully ungroup but it's not for some
reason so right click
oh it's shift g that's
that's why
bring that down shift g
um i'm hitting right click
and hitting e
to boom up to move the camera up
boom and i'm just going to group these
again
ctrl g
well group shift g
will ungroup good to know all right
so we have our ladder we have our water
we have our columns we have our material
we have our lighting like so much of
this is
we're we're getting close we're getting
very very close
um
i'm just saying things this this isn't
that close but it's pretty darn close
we got the vibe we just need to spice it
up
so um here's another thing i'll do
because it's getting us closer to the
vibe as quickly as possible is the color
correction right you can see here that i
colored this a bit more green
cyan
um
definitely a green cast to it so
i'm going to use the post process volume
to do that all right
um so if i
scroll down here let's see color
correction color grading that's what we
want
we want global okay
so we can take
the gamma
i'll check that
and just kind of pull this towards
the green
hue here
just a little something very matrixy
big fan
like just even a little bit of that it
takes us a little bit closer to the vibe
and we could
you know if you want you could go to
town here
well you know why not why not so let's
try
the shadows
the gamma of the shadows
will pull towards like a
purple or something
[Music]
we can do
mid-tones
to that green
[Music]
i like to go overboard and then walk it
back
and the highlights
we can push towards uh
like a bluish
green or something
and we can go global gamma
as well
you know you do a lot of stuff you can
go to town here but i'm not i'm not
spending too much time on the color
correction but just a little something
to get the vibes right and while we're
at it in the post-process volume
vignette is a big move here we can check
that on
and just work in a little bit to help
our vibes
get a little closer to what we're going
for
all right
now
we can start
adding and painting
on this rubble i'm not hand placing that
that's going to be a mess
but before we do that let's go ahead and
um
place the bigger chunks okay
so once again
well first off how's everybody doing
how's everyone doing let's let's take a
moment just to see let's check in with
everybody
ah
what's going on everyone
ah of course we got soto in the house
always
in my ear telling me what's good with it
um he's behind the scenes making sure
that the stream runs smooth i saw a
visual another one of the moderators
popping in here good to see you
melvin how's it going
tesla rock yo yo
heck yeah
everyone doing all right if you guys are
following along give me a thumbs up
hopefully i'm not going too fast for you
you can always pause this thing later
papaxo what is going on stiles morales
what's up dude
um
henry absolutely man yeah it was fun
judging the rococo loop challenge such
such awesome renders
what else do we got
who's that who who's up in here
heck yeah that's good good to see you
guys we got some thumbs ups here
people hanging out working along with me
zack b you're learning maya good luck to
you very cool
churlish vr hello from australia
that's what's up
azaz we we're going to get you something
good before you go to bed here
nice jameson doing 3d art and blender so
i really guys it really doesn't matter
like
what program you're using you've hear
you've heard me say this a million times
it doesn't matter what program you're
using
as long as you're creating cool stuff
um i mean but hey if you don't want to
create cool stuff that's cool too
but if you all trying to be creative and
are trying to create some cool stuff
then it doesn't matter what program
you're using i'm using unreal because
that's my personal journey you guys use
whatever you want um and these live
streams
they're not
here to force anyone to do a certain
thing
or to use a certain tool or whatever
it's just it's creative time so while
i'm working you guys could be working on
your stuff too we're working together it
could be on the same thing it could be
on separate stuff we're just hanging out
and working together so yeah good times
very good times oh man cambodia we got
india
that's awesome
thailand that's what's up
germany ukraine
wow man
we got a awesome kenya
ghana dang
dan you guys are all over the place
that's great
more india spain
yes
yes
i love it got the international
worldwide audience
we got
uk
man y'all are awesome all right let's
get back into it we got some people who
are trying to get to bed you know it's
late
okay
sweden nigeria nepal finland taiwan
heck yeah
france
saudi arabia
that's what's up
canada
shout outs
all right we got one person from la
that's great
i too am in la
all right
let's um
let's add the bigger chunks okay
so we have mega scans 3d assets you all
know you see me do it top left qixel
bridge this all comes free
with unreal engine you're going to go to
3d assets you're going to search for the
assets you want um if you just look up
under assets 3d assets concrete or
rubble or whatever they they got stuff
for days up in here so
you just browse the site
find the stuff that works for you
and we're gonna do it nice all right so
asphalt debris okay that's smaller stuff
smaller stuff
all right we got some some stuff here
i'm just gonna lay out the bigger items
we got some rubble
this is pretty small still but we can
scale it
um
more rubble pile okay this is where we
start getting good here
start getting good here yup yup yup yup
okay
nice little like
patch
of dirt there we got some stairs
probably not going to use those branches
we're going to come to those branches
later yeah work big and go small
containers metal containers pipes
pill a pillow some boards all this stuff
is based off of me looking at the
reference and seeing what's scattered
around but we're gonna get there
um
concrete pillar and a trash bag okay so
we got our our main
big pieces here okay
so we
want to scatter these around
as like say like little islands
around this
little well here or reserve water
reserve it's not a sewer technically
it's not a sewer
so stuff has fallen down
this is crazy like
look at this pipe
and we have a poweraid
we got water bottles we got snacks we
got
sticks
little ferns and
cans and just bunch of stuff little
rocks
all these are things that have fallen
down here
over the years and they've kind of piled
up
by the by the the bottom of this ladder
by the base of this ladder and it just
gets a little thinner as you come out
towards uh the back of this thing so
you know we see our sticks bunch of
branches rocks boards all that good
stuff
and again that's what
why i'm pulling these specific items
from kwixel
um so yeah let's make let's make some
little islands where all this stuff can
kind of be populated on to
all right and you can see my texture
went out because who knows why
it doesn't really matter at this point
it'll come back later if we give it a
restart or something but let's place all
this stuff right i'm going to scale this
up a bit
maybe scrunch it down and kind of just
cover up the corners
we'll get it below
the surface of the water
we can get this mound
uh scroll wheel will control camera
speed guys it's also on the top
right up there
let's maybe get like a little area in
here
we can scale it down i'm hitting
spacebar to cycle between the gizmos
drop it below the floor of course
and let's switch these because
this one is a little
bigger
cool
and holding alt we can duplicate
and i'll build up some
little islands at the base
of
these pillars here
scrunch it down pull it up
see that's looking pretty sweet
that's looking pretty sweet
same deal here hold alt
spacebar to toggle between the gizmos
flatten it down and
give these pillars a little something to
stand on
we can orbit this and we can also turn
up
the brightness so let's go to
our post process volume or no was it in
the camera we type brightness
and let's just go up a stop on both of
these just so we can kind of see what
we're doing
very nice these guys can scale up i'm
going to use this as like
little chunks in the water
kind of going for
chunkage you know general chunkage in
the water that's that's exactly what i'm
going for so i'm gonna scale this down
just flatten it like that
and then drop it and you can see
we got some general
chunkage
in the water
and you can scatter that around or
rather duplicate i'm gonna scale this up
too
boom boom
drop it
chunks
bam immediate chunks all right what else
um
oh loving them chunks
that's looking good
and we have a little dirt patch here
we can probably get this dirt patch we
can scale this thing up
put this up in the corners and stuff
um
yeah yep
rotate
and flatten
don't want it all looking the same here
um chunks
so we'll go from the main islands we'll
kind of like
we'll get smaller and smaller the
islands are the biggest
and then we'll go small small small
off into the water right
so
let's duplicate this
orbit
drop a little lower
bam
sky orbit
and we can even raise it up
and drop it down
and constantly be looking at like your
camera angle view okay
you always want to be looking where
you're going to be shooting from so that
for me that's going to be here it could
be all over
um it's also up here based off of the
thumbnail and the art and it could also
be like off to the side low off to the
side
um
holding alt still i'm duplicating
orbit so it doesn't look like a
duplicate
we can even like stretch it a little bit
and just
try to fill in
the edges here
boom
stretch
raise it up
maybe it's a little too stretched
bam
pretty nice let's get
we got this guy we haven't used this one
yet
it's just you know back and forth
working everything in
[Music]
i was definitely inspired by some bob
ross you know um i watched a little
youtube video on them and they were
talking about how he he creates
a
piece of art he creates three pieces of
art
one before the show
so he kind of gets an idea of what he's
going to be doing on the show so it's
not this first time on the show and
that's exactly what i'm doing here i
created this
previously
um
as you can see right
here we built this out um this this was
just yesterday only yesterday i did this
which is crazy to think about before i
couldn't imagine doing this in one day
um and now i'm about to do it in
in three hours so it's pretty nuts but
um
yeah this was my round one the stream
will be round two and i'm not going pro
bob ross
doing a third one after the fact like
maybe i'll touch up this original one
right here maybe um
but
i think it just makes for better streams
it gets us to the point faster um i'm a
bit more educated on what i'm teaching
or rather doing i feel i don't feel like
i'm really teaching i feel like i'm just
kind of talking out what i'm doing um
whether it's right or wrong who knows
but we're gonna get there we're gonna
get there it's gonna look good i promise
so let's grab we're you know we're
making our way downtown we're walking
real fast um
walking super fast all right
let's just get let's just go on and get
this scaled
on
it's killing up
yeah
come on boy
there we go chunks bam
loving them chunks okay
let's keep
placing things um
boom
we can scale this way
down
wonderful
we got some chunks back here they're
looking nice
yes indeed
and
can pull some of this
and we're
pretty much there we don't need to
fill in all the detail with these main
island bits
um
but
it's
it's gonna help us certainly
um place all of these pieces of trash
and boards and sticks and cans and
all that good stuff that's gonna help us
do all that stuff so
[Music]
chunks
amazing
scale this boy up
[Music]
boom d von williams
in the chat my goodness with the super
chat too
my son you know what you just did
you just you just purchased me
a kombucha thank you devon
thank you for that boot son it is a
brand new day it's a brand new stream
son
yes
d bon
williams man you ever get charged for
that
for those tuxedo pants you ripped
i don't think i got charged for my shirt
i don't think marcus got charged for his
pants either
it was a good wedding y'all it was a
good wedding
um
good to see here devon i miss you man
i'm just sitting here all alone
i'm not even sitting down i'm standing
up
doing 3d art that's cool we got you
y'all y'all here in spirit
y'all here on the internet waves
i ain't alone okay
i think we have enough to start building
out
uh all the scatter so i am going to
restart unreal to get that
texture back but you know what i wonder
if this works hold on
let me try loading
another level
and hopping back in and see if that
works
oh is it worse
how is it worse oh just because i'm not
okay let me restart this real quick
[Music]
me
[Applause]
[Laughter]
[Applause]
all right we're back we're back
um
this is the one that i made yesterday
let's open up that
string here we go now it's loaded right
click that dang thing pilot this damn
camera and we are back
sweet all right um
hmm
let's start painting so you all know
that
qixel bridge is a thing
i think we have established that many
times on this live stream
uh went to 3d assets i looked up trash
rubble dirt rocks dust whatever the heck
all 3d assets that
came from my reference i looked at the
reference what's in my reference logs
rocks
paint cans
uh bottles sticks
more
rocks more sticks
let's get a little closer what do we see
tiny sticks tiny rocks
pipes metal stuff
infrastructure cans
man this is a just a trash heap
just a trash heap
so
um let us
go back to unreal
knowing what we need to pull from qixel
bridge
you know space off your reference i
can't say
say it enough reference is very very
important
um let me restart this damn camera too
um
come on now
let's go bowie
camera's back all right camera's back it
could happen again you know
technical difficulties
they they're out there they're coming
for you
okay
so what i did is i went through bridge i
favorited all my favorite stuff
and
we have these 3d objects here in our
scene under the 3d assets mega scans
folder
now
we're going to paint this stuff onto our
scene
and the way i'm going to do that is by
going top left
select mode and we're going to go to
foliage
all right and we're going to drag and
drop all the different bits of foliage
and in this case it's not just foliage
it's rocks dirt dust
bottles cans
sticks rocks you can paint anything i
could have painted these large chunks of
landscape
um
so let's go through one by one add them
paint them
and see what it looks like okay
we'll start with these little chunkers
these little rocky guys i'm gonna drag
them in
this foliage and by default they're all
checked right so that means when i start
painting they're gonna be scattered
around the scene you can hold shift
click and that's going to erase
these little guys
yeah
but let's set them up
so that we don't just start painting by
default and we want to
give this a little bit of art direction
and
and some uh some style make sure things
are looking as good as possible so
let us
do some testing right so i'm going to
paint it on this rock
and we can see that they're kind of
scattered around like little oreo bits
right
we can control
if i select them all on the left side we
can control the density so if i crank
the density to a thousand
you know
it nothing changes weird okay
wait did i not change it
there we go they're just a little denser
now
um
could also adjust
the
scale right so we can say they're
anywhere between
their default size and two times bigger
right
or their default size and five times
bigger
you can scatter these around the density
is really intense
oreo town all right
but we don't want that i think a density
a size of of one and one is fine
and a density of 100 is
probably great
maybe even 80.
the other thing we can do is rotation we
can take the random pitch angle to 360
that's where it maxes out 359
technically and it's just going to
randomly rotate these pieces
and i think that's kind of cool
but is it cool if they're also flat like
you just don't want them to look
uniform too uniform and i think this
actually is not bad
maybe i can take that to like 25 so
there's a little bit of rotation in
these things
so i think those are set up we're good
let's keep going down down the list
cinder blocks let's drag our cinder
blocks in
and let's deselect
uh here's what i'm gonna do guys i'm
gonna take off
this content browser so we can kind of
see a little bit more of what's going on
with this paint
situation
um
and i'm just gonna move the content
browser
over
come on now
over to my other window
and y'all just trust that i'm pulling
from that content browser all right also
freaking p
quad goodness gracious
thank you very much for that that is a
very generous super chat from you good
sir
p quad i love that name
pec peckham peckwood
i don't know uh you say good morning do
you recommend operating with ue5 as an
alternative for other paid rendering
solutions octane for c4d as it offers a
whole lot asset wise um i freaking love
unreal there's no reason not to get into
unreal because it's very powerful it's
free
i freaking love it it is the best
now c4d
an octane that has a different place
in my heart
and it always will
it's better for
if you're really going for like final
render final production quality
um and you want things to look good
right out the gates
um you know a non-bias renderer is
probably what you want it doesn't have
to be c4d octane that is what i use i do
love it very much that is a great combo
um but of course blender is a thing too
you got maya
um those are those are kind of the main
ones
right now 3ds max is still around it's
just not as updated
but i'd say man like
i i was trying to fill the hole i was
trying to feel like what's the
difference
um let me try and restart this damn
camera again
i'm sorry guys
um
i was trying to figure out like
why do i need unreal engine and this is
exactly why to make these environments
in real time i was inspired by memories
of australia super awesome short film i
was inspired by qixel rebirth really
awesome short film there's a whole lot
of good stuff coming out of unreal
engine environment wise and i think it's
perfect for that i love environments i
love traveling so it's a great way for
me to create
literally the places i've traveled to
like i have been in this sewer that is
the coolest thing ever um and i'm
creating this based off of reference
photography i took in this sewer or a
well i guess or
whatever you call it um
so
it's a really fun fast and easy way to
create you know if we can take what's in
our heads and put it off
into
the screen if we can create something
from our heads to
a canvas as quickly as possible that's
the goal right so unreal helps me do
that immediately by
just immediately seeing what it's going
to look like
so i love it
and thanks again for that super chat
very generous of you back to it i'm
going to select
the asphalt i'm going to deselect all
those right shift click deselect them so
we're just messing with our new asset
these are cinder blocks
and by default they are too small and
they're too uniform
so i
am going to make some adjustments
i think there's too many of them so
let's take the density down to like 50.
they're too small so let's take it up
from let's take it to two
we're gonna double them in size
and they also
i think are still
there's too many of them
so let's take
this to like 15 density to 15.
that feels a bit better to me i'll even
go
nine or something um because i don't
want a ton of these assets
everywhere right that's even that's
still a lot
the last thing is rotation they're all
standing up and we don't
really want that we want them to be
in different orientations so i'll scroll
down just a touch and take that random
pitch angle to let's let's see what 360
looks like
and i think that's a lot better
we could
try like just 90 degrees and see
it's not bad
it's better than what is before i'll
take it to like 120 or something
um and then i'm actually going to move
it down so the max height
is
oh wait no that's like i
yeah cuz i want them to be like in the
water i think they're fine it'll be fine
when we paint other stuff
but that looks good to me right
now let's move on and set up our our
second asset so or our third rather
deselect those let's bring in
what's next on the list i'm just looking
in the content browser on my other
screen
rubble pack we have a rubble pack i'm
going to grab all of these
and drop them in okay
[Music]
right they're all selected by default
scatter them around that's looking
pretty sweet there's just a lot of them
i don't want it to be too many of one
specific thing
um
so i'm gonna take this density also down
to probably 10 as well
and i like the way this stuff looks i
think
these they look cooler
flatter because they catch the light a
little bit more
um i'll give them a little bit of random
rotation so maybe like
15 degrees
but they're not looking uniform by
default which is great i think we're
solid there we can even
take the density down to like six
we don't want too many big things
kind of hogging
this
this whole random assortment of stuff
we're going to paint all this together
at one time we're going to toggle
everything together but we got to keep
going through
and setting our stuff up one by one here
we're about halfway down the list here's
another one
this is another rubble pack i think
these are a bit smaller let's paint
these and see what they look like
nice
let's take the
density down
to like 20.
yep and then we can
i mean honestly i think that looks great
moving on
um
dead branches yes
let's grab our branches bring them in
now there's a lot of branches so i might
leave these guys
that's a lot though
okay let's take the max size to 2
the minimum to 0.5 okay
density wise i think we can probably
take it to like
60
just so they're not consuming everything
but i think that looks pretty
awesome
deselect those
count those as good to go
um
we have branches as well we have more
branches
let's see what do these branches offer
these are like
just more branches i don't know if we
need them
we can make them like
little tiny guys maybe
um
0.25 to 0.5 with a density of like 50.
so like little sticks
little sticks
i'm down for that
okay
um
we have
metal containers
let's see what metal
containers look like we got some boxes
i'm actually going to take these boxes
out it's just too boxy
be gone
and we have some cans
obviously this is way too uniform and
too many so i'm going to set this
density to like
10
and i'm also going to set the
minimum scale to 0.5
as well as the rotation to 360.
that feels a lot better to me
i'm down with that sweet
moving on we got pipes
um
let's grab some pipe pieces
i'll just want to grab these two
right here and right here
let's paint these and see what they look
like
all right there's a ton of them
how many pipes fell down okay not that
many
let's take this to 10 as well
rotation angle we can also do 360
and i think i'm cool with the size
oh but they're like see-through and
stuff so i am going to delete those
no good
oh we still have our
branches in here let's get rid of these
branches i'm going to select all the
branches
they are already selected that is great
and i'm going to hold shift and erase
[Music]
because we don't need them yet
that's fine there's a couple in there
but whatever um
old containers yes all right so we got a
bunch of like laundry detergent
containers and stuff
let's scatter those
obviously way too much
let's take the density back down to 10.
so
they're in here but they're not like
i'll even take it to 8.
size is fine 360
on the angle so
that looks good to me
i'll even take that density to like
six
and we're almost done
we have our wooden boards the wooden
boards yes these are important
very important
boom
it's all it always starts off as too
many all right
i'll set it to 15.
dude i'm painting these things sticks
too
get you see how it's all it's all
painting together whatever's checked is
being painted okay we're gonna turn all
these on once we're once we're done
we're almost done
these boards are looking nice
let's set
the rotation angle to like 30 degrees
they kind of look like bricks but that's
okay i'm going to set it to 10
and then we have
some bigger boards
to close it out with
wait a second i'm so confused
these are the big boards
there we go these guys are awesome
so i'm gonna take those i'm gonna max
them out at like 1.5
minimum 0.5 density 15
rotation angle 30 and let's kind of just
see what that looks like i think that's
freaking sweet
that looks great so now when we take all
of this we turn all of it on
now
we're painting with trash
and we're gonna go to town here
brush size let's go 50 son
that is a lot of
cinder blocks so maybe i will dial back
on the cinder block density
boom
boom
take it to like six or something we got
a super chat who is out alec
alec tucker
goodness gracious thank you
for the super chat thank you for the
content you work at epic and use you e
every day gets to learn so much from the
content reach out if you ever need help
dude that is awesome man heck yeah
that is what's up
man
yeah this program is freaking sweet it's
so much fun every single day well i'm
glad you learned it i appreciate the
super chat uh thanks for showing some
love
i'm excited to paint some trash
all right
so camera angles we're talking like here
and there goes my texture again it's
cool we'll come back
we're talking here
so we do need to fill this out
i'm thinking we got some pileage up on
here
it's falling down
like all up on here you know
out into here
all up on this all up on that
those dang cinder blocks those dang
cinder blocks
i'ma get these things
ooh i'm gonna get these things uh
let's scale them down
and let's
rotate them even more
and let's take their density to like
three
and i'm gonna erase
some of them the reason um
my pointer and this
little cursor aren't lined up is because
i'm in a camera that has a specific
aspect ratio
so it's a little like
a little disjointed
sweet all right back to it
i'm gonna go too thick back here um we
can take the
density if we go zero let's see does
that yeah it does cool
we can take
the density down to like half
and take our brush size up
and just kind of do a light a light
glazing
of sewage
this looks freaking great
this looks awesome
amazing
amazing dang
we got
two powerful super chats up in here um
alpha
toad
um amazing man thank you so much you are
one of my favorite creators on youtube
that is
some very generous words i appreciate
that from the mind-boggling montages of
the highest quality community driven
projects of all time to the best unreal
tutorials out there you are constantly
inspiring you inspiring me love you my
man thank you alpha that is awesome
thank you for the praise thank you for
the kind words i do what i can i always
got to do my best that's the thing it's
like i can't i can't do a halfway job
and you know since doing uh
doing that unreal
stream a month ago
and realizing like how great it was and
how awesome and how much fun it was and
it's like i i got to put more into these
streams so doing the art beforehand and
getting to the point where i can quickly
work on this stuff live here with you
guys it's the way to go
um so thank you alpha and dylan thank
you very very much
i love your content got me inspired to
start blender and now i'm doing creative
media course yes that's what's up
heck yeah man keep it up keep it up keep
that fire going it's very important
thanks for stopping by and thank you for
saying hey
um an s
man i'm gonna butcher this i'm so sorry
espjorn
rizberg
that's a pretty sweet name
thank you for that super chat no no
message necessary just a
straight up little support from a lego
man
thank you lego person
um
cool cool cool now this is looking
awesome um minus our texture going out
which it's gonna happen
we just gotta do a little restart it'll
come back
um
[Music]
yes yes
yes okay
this is pretty darn close here's the
thing guys here's here's the thing i'm
doing that you didn't see me do because
i didn't do it yet
um and that
is to make these assets
that we just painted and these little
like uh
these little islands of rubble that we
laid out is to make them feel and appear
wet okay and the way i'm doing that
is by
finding whatever the asset is let's say
it's this one i'm gonna hit control b
for browse and that's gonna open up your
content browser i got it on the other
let me let me actually just
let me just dock it again
what
get
dang camera
hmm
i don't know what it is y'all
i don't know why it keeps overheating or
something
it's the thing anyway as long as you can
hear me and see the video and see the
stream we're doing good stuff
okay
so
what
is
next i was talking about wetness of this
thing okay are you gonna hit ctrl b
you're gonna browse to the asset
boom right you're gonna double click the
material instance and this is where you
can
adjust its parameters like uh
how shiny it is is it is it not shiny at
all or is it full shiny
um i had it set to 0.8
the roughness that's how matte
it uh the reflection appears is it like
a mirror or is it leather you know
leather still is reflective
it's just not shiny super you know
crispy reflection like a mirror would be
so
one is full roughness zero is crispy
like a mirror i think i had that set to
0.8 um so what i do
usually with these mega scans
materials the default is like this the
base specular is 0.5
the roughness is one
but if you want it to appear more shiny
and catch the light which i really want
to i want it to feel wet
we're going to go
full shininess
full reflectivity
right
so we're going to take the specular to
one and the roughness
the closer you remember the closer you
get to zero
the more crispy it it feels right the
more like soaked and wet it feels and i
think i had to set the point eight
so it's a nice
nice little uh
subtle gloss
on this guy
you know without it you wouldn't be
getting this this bounce light same for
all this stuff you know you wouldn't be
getting
like this rock right here you see this
rock
from this angle
it's not really reflective but as we
go towards the light you can see it's
really catching
this light
off the side of that asset
so that's what you want
is the webcam gone again
[Music]
shoot
that's not good
i'm just gonna let it cool off maybe
it's uh
heat it up a little much
but we'll get there so next what i'm
gonna do
we're probably at the point now
i can i can i think i can like
grab some of these and duplicate them
over and and they actually come with the
rubble
that was painted onto them so that's
pretty sweet
all right so you can fill things in that
way if you'd like if you want to get a
little bit more uh
chunkage going right so i can take this
whole thing move it over alt drag
kind of bring it
right back in on here
very very nice
so now
i think we can talk about
let's try and get the lighting
closer
to a final image okay
so i'm gonna get rid of this dude
right now
and i believe i'm gonna need to do a
quick restart
that way i can get my textures back
so bear with me while i do that
[Music]
[Laughter]
l tell me what what is the fix
ah okay
l dot
type r dot streaming that pool size 3000
keeps your textures going
from low res all the time default is a
thousand
and it's not hard to go over the limit
okay
that is
great news that is great news
all right
let's hop into
this guy
and let's follow elle's advice
l from
uh
death note l
it might be could it be
r
dot streaming
dot pool size
3 000.
yes thank you thank you thank you thank
you
that is some golden advice
heck yeah
all right bran doom technically this is
the native flute i was playing just then
the native american flute the
gosu tsushima flute that is called a
shakuhachi
and apparently that's really hard to
play
it's hard to even get a sound out of the
native flute is cool because
if you can blow into a
a bottle and make a sound
you know
it's technically harder
to do that than it is to play the native
flute so
all right
let's see if we can't get our lighting
looking better
all right
if i were to
take off um let me reset this real quick
[Music]
yes that is what we want
pilot camera
okay
let's take off our directional light and
see what happens alright so we're
definitely getting a lot of lift in our
scene from the direction of light but
we're getting this spill
over the top
and the edge of this thing and i think
it's because
it's so bright i think it's because it's
coming right to the edge it needs to
technically like
be a little bit larger than it and a
little bit lower so let's see if that
helps us i'm gonna bring it down a touch
and i'm gonna scale it up
what
is that scaling up i can't tell that's
okay
and then i'm just gonna cap it bring it
on down
[Music]
all right still not doing it let's um
let's mess with our rectangle light
because that's you know it's technically
what's doing it
wow that looks
that looks cool where the heck is this
light coming from
oh my god
oh okay so it's still shining through
that
sweet all right let's try
let's grab our sun
and we want to point our sun just a
little bit further in
let's take that red light and maybe just
scale it down
yo that like solved
everything i just scaled it down
i also wonder if like
placing walls on the outside of this
thing
could help with this let me just try it
um
let me take
yeah so under lit i just unchecked game
settings and
we can adjust our
exposure that way let's try doing uh
well i guess first we can
make sure that's correct
all right under
when you started your project you can
start it with
um
starter content
that way you can like tap into
all their different
you know materials and
and assets and there's some walls here
that we can pull out
boom right we'll scale that up we got a
super chat
you're an environment artist with 1.5
years of work experience recently
completed a contract
but now need to find a new job getting a
lot of rejection even with one plus year
of work experience i guess i need to
make more projects and update my
portfolio please keep teaching us don't
stop
um
shoot yeah well thank you for the super
chat that's very kind of you
um
that's a tough one that is certainly a
tough one
and
you know
with job stuff like
i'm gonna be honest with you i haven't
like bid for a freelance job
or
or attempted to get a um
you know like a studio job
in
a very long time maybe even i don't even
know if i've if i've had to do had to do
that so
you know definitely take whatever i'm
about to say
uh with a grain of salt i don't
understand
that
that saying but you know what i mean um
you know there's there's outside factors
that
you cannot control when it comes to job
stuff i mean when it comes to life
obviously
um you can only do your best
and then it comes down to like
you know
do they know someone
uh
and they are they hiring based off of
them knowing someone for a long time
because they're a friend or
you know or maybe the company doesn't
need x y and z they need some other
thing they need a b and c
so it's really tough
um
job hunting is very very tough
i've had friends go through it um
close relatives loved ones
and like
it's a tough situation because
you're constantly being rejected
and that doesn't feel good
um
you're like what am i doing wrong what
am i doing wrong and you may not be
doing anything wrong
one thing you can be doing though is
talking with other professionals in your
field
that you want to
um
you know you see yourself doing their
job they've done the job that you want
so you talk to them about like what are
some things or some pointers and tips so
that's a great way to
stay connected to make connections and
to also
get advice on what you can specifically
be doing to update your resume
you know so
we're fine what what's a
average price it's a fair price etc etc
um this is just network
and get to know people so
that's about all i can offer advice wise
on that i'd say just you know keep it up
keep having fun and at the end of the
day just keep that spark going you know
try not to lose that passion and if you
do it's okay take a break
go on a vacation if you can
um
it'll come back to you for sure
all right i'm dropping a
fully black solid
onto these guys um
i'm also
gonna do a little ceiling cover
so it's like no light is getting in you
know what i mean
except for where it really needs
to get in
that's the idea with what i'm doing
right now
and we'll we'll see if it makes a
difference it may not
and we might just have to keep tweaking
our lights
that made a massive difference
oh but it's because
we need to change our exposure
yo that fixed it
that fixed it
sweet okay let's shape our light a
little bit more i don't like that it's
just a square down here i want it to be
a little bit more soft so
let's see what we can do
um based off of our reference right
always going back to our reference there
is not a square of light it is a very
soft fall off so let's see if we can't
emulate that look
hmm
yeah herman you're right it's it's thin
my ceiling is thin it needs to be
thicker
definitely i think it was like a 10
centimeters steve begin
was telling me yesterday i was like
steve why
does this happen he was like dude you
got to have your geometry be 10 meters
10 centimeters thick or else lumen is
going to light leak through the dang
thing so
keep that in mind y'all
um let's get this light looking good and
we're going to add some
graffiti
all right directional light
and the wreck light so a lot of this
dang that just looks freaking sweet
you can do so many different
types of lighting here guys
uh but that directional light we can
crank it okay we can take it to like an
intensity of 30.
and look at that just so much bounce
light in our scene
really looks nice
um
the only reason i'm really using a
rectangle light is to get that
um
that cone shape
up here
now again
it is very very harsh here
so we need to soften that up
by
we can do it a couple different ways we
can make the light larger but we found
that that
gave us that light leak situation so we
could pull it up
and move it a little bit
you know something something like that
is not
half bad
what the heck is going on
another thing i want to do is uh
actually look out to white
just like the reference it goes straight
to white
so i'm going to take
this wall
let's duplicate it
move it up
moving on up
get it right to the edge there
we'll scale it down because we still
want light to come through we don't want
to block any light
but we just want
enough
so
we are looking at white as opposed to
black and white we wanted to we want to
fake the sky
um so we just got to grab
the white solid
yeah there you go boom
looks great
all right let's keep messing with our
rec light
i like that shadow
on
the actual ladder i think that looks
really cool
so we can maybe like move it this way
i mean like that
looks pretty dark good and then we can
see about rotation
turn on snapping or turn off snapping
rather
and we can take our sun
directional light we can crank it to
like 50 so it's really bright but then
we take our source angle if i turn off
the wreck light we take the source angle
and
we take it up to 10
take it up to 20
take it up to 30.
all right it's gonna
wow it's gonna screw up
every three
so here's what i'll do
let's try
one of these
little blockers
a flag and we'll duplicate it under the
floor here
and we'll see if this helps us
nope
[Music]
it probably has something to do with
like
huh
don't know why it's leaking like that
[Music]
i mean we're probably just going too
hard on the
on the sunlight we're just breaking it
so we need to dial it back um
let's grab our sunlight
directional light
and the source angle
bam alright we reset it
and let's grab
our wrecked light
and let's do let's do this in a couple
different lights i'm still trying to get
rid of that like
that spot on the ground there oh i know
we can do attenuation radius that is how
we'll do it so the light
just goes
right so attenuation radius on the rect
light if we pull that back remember
earlier we max it out right
so we just get it so
perfect right
perfect
it's beautiful
bam
[Music]
let's give this camera another shot too
yeah
all right that looks nice i'll make
another wreck light
um
inside right so i'm going to drag
another wrecked light out
bang
space bar let's turn on our angle snaps
get that to 90
and
center it up
g will allow us to
see
our different icons and stuff i'm going
to bring it up up up come on now come on
boy
let's bring this up up up
cool and let's control
the uh the barn doors right
so this is something that you see
on movie sets
where you can control the barn doors so
it blocks the light from hitting certain
spots which is exactly what we want to
do so we open up those barn doors
we want to focus it down and we want to
extend the barn doors so we're shooting
like a like a spotlight almost
bam right there and then we'll just
bring the intensity down
so that's that's off
and that
boom is pretty darn perfect so we're
cheating it right we're cheating that
look
but that's what you gotta do you gotta
cheat it and it looks great
[Music]
all right i'm gonna
bring some of this stuff
into our geometry
this goes into our lighting
so now we're all clean
and it's looking darn good
[Music]
yes
yes yes yes yes yes so we cheated it
right we got our uh three lights we're
doing this with three lights
we have our sunlight
boom
shining straight down
onto this little area here we have our
first rectangular light which is up
above
way up in the sky oh no it's literally
right there boom just on the outside of
that entrance
and that
is blasting this wall giving you that
nice cone shape we're cranking the
attenuation radius so
it's not hitting the floor and then
we're using
a third one
right to get us that nice soft light
look
and we might be able to take the
directional light
our sun
bring the intensity down we can do the
same for the second
wrecked light
bring the intensity
down something like that i think that
can look pretty sweet
directional light we can still
take down and maybe
nah
nah i like that that looks nice let's
take our uh
in the directional light
the volumetric scattering intensity if
we take that up
we're going to get
a
nice
little
beam of light
but i think honestly that takes away
from the whole thing
because that's really what we want um if
we take our exponential height fog and
we give it a little bit more
goodness gracious
0.01
0.02 it doesn't need a lot 0.05
0.04
0.03
0.025 perhaps
all right you have a little bit there
just kind of sweet we can take the
directional light and soften that up so
remember when we went too hard with it
it did this whole weirdness thing here
let's crank it until we let's bring it
back down until it's not there anymore
because that'll spread out
should spread out that volumetric
maybe maybe it doesn't actually
maybe
i don't know what i'm talking about
[Music]
all right
heck yeah guys we've been we got 745
people up in the live stream right now
that is awesome
thank you guys
and we're growing too that's great
yo i am almost almost at a million
subscribers if you ain't subscribed
already now is the time if you're
learning something if you're getting a
little education on if you're having fun
we're close to a million y'all
started this channel in 2006.
freaking
almost what is that 2006 66 like 16
years or something
all right
so
let's add some graffiti shall we
let's add some graffiti
all right so the way i'm doing that
is with they are called decals all right
and again
we're going top left quixle bridge
we're going to navigate to
decals
specifically graffiti
and i just pulled a number
of little graffiti bits
um
stuff that looked a little bit more
natural
as opposed to
i don't know
it's tough with the graffiti
because it can very quickly feel like
it's they're just assets
especially based on what they say i'd
rather not
you not know what they say
and the little
bit that i know about graffiti
um apparently
you'll have tigers go they'll make
a tag
right
and then you might have some artists
who come and remix it
or you have someone who's tagged over it
um very similar to tony hawk
pro skater where you know you're tagging
different uh different ramps and then
someone comes and tags over your ramp so
you're gonna see a lot of graffiti on
top of graffiti um here some of it is
more artistic than the other than others
so what i try to do is like
uh for this art
i will
have a bigger piece like this that had a
little bit more thought put into it
like you see on the right and the left
here and even back behind here right you
can tell a little some work was put into
that
and then you have like the lazier ones
that come on top and just like
trash the ones that
that are looking good and then you'll
probably have someone come and do
something over top all of that right so
it just keeps stacking also another
thing to note for this scene
specifically is that people are coming
down this ladder right most people are
right-handed so they're probably hitting
this with their right hand you're gonna
have more graffiti on the right side
then on the left
um and it's from the top coming all the
way down to the bottom there's graffiti
right and you consider how tall someone
is too
graffiti's not going to be up in this
random spot it's going to be in the
accessible spots right
so
let's
play some graffiti shall we
okay
okay i'm gonna move the content browser
again
up on out of here
so we have a little nicer view and i'm
even going to get rid of the place
actors window
so we can
just have a better view of what's going
on here
all right let's start with
one of the bigger
pieces
we'll drag this out and by default you
can see it's like sticking
to surfaces
but the orientation is not correct i
think it's actually oriented
down like this
so we need to rotate it
and i'll make sure snapping is on
90 degrees i think it's upside down
we'll go 180
right and it's a volume the way it works
it's really cool
so if we hit g
you can kind of see what's going on
right there's this box
here and it's taking up a
space
and we're gonna
move it if you move it forward and back
right it'll be on the wall if it's like
too scrunched for you if i can
get this right if it's too flat
you're not you're gonna have a hard time
getting it on the wall
so you wanna make sure that it is
indeed a volume
it's a cube right
so that we can get it up on this wall i
think it's a little big
and it's cool it like maintains the
the normal
data from
the layer underneath
is pretty sweet
so
there's one of our main pieces
let's grab another one
um
and we should be placing
some graffiti all
[Music]
bam
let's get some more larger ones
[Music]
sweet
and this just you know this just takes
time
time and patience
i spent a while
getting all this art
and these decals up on this wall
and we'll go
one more
sure let's try this one
and of course you can you know change
the colors of these
by clicking on
the texture
changing the hue or the material
instance and
changing the tint perhaps
again i'm hitting g
so i can actually
see what's going on
control backtick backtick is the button
next to your one key on the keyboard
that's gonna switch between local and
world world orientation
for some reason when i scale it down it
also
doesn't scale it uniformly which is
annoying
i feel like
there's got to be a way to do that
cool so we kind of have like our four
main
ones here
um
and from here what we'll do is we'll
just kind of like
go over top
and
really mess it up with some smaller bits
of graffiti
bam yeah like this
over and over
and over again
[Music]
oh i like this one
this is a good one
[Music]
[Music]
and this is something that y'all can you
can take days on this thing you know
like i said i i worked yesterday on this
building out this whole scene
um
i could easily spend a week
you know
what the heck
there we go that's still i don't know
why it's not scaling uniformly
and this is just one of those things
that
you can't do
a halfway job on the graffiti it has to
be
like it only works if there's a lot of
it so
you know you just just be aware of what
you're getting into
but that's what that's what it takes you
know as an artist that's what it takes
it takes patience
time and effort
to really get the details right spend
most of your time
on the details right
i talked about that in my last video
we talked about um you know
you're gonna you're gonna be spending
most of the details anyway
so you might as well get to the point
where
set yourself up
to uh get to the point where you can
work on the details as fast as possible
so you'll spend
20 percent of your time getting to the
80 mark and then you'll spend
80 percent of your time
on the last 20
of your render essentially
right
because the details that's what that's
what counts
i'm just going down the list i think um
i'm more than halfway through here
on these different tags so
i'll get to the end and
we'll call it we don't have to go
all out we only have so much time
[Music]
and you could easily do custom
tags here too you know
if you want to do uh
decals on top of decals and you want the
order to be different if you select the
decal
and if you type sort order
you can change this
and it'll move up in the queue
in the layer stack and that's that's
exactly
what we want so
beautiful
and qixel has a ton of different
decals too they're not just graffiti
they um
they have leaks and
potholes and
literally anything you can think of they
got it i'll put some like water leaks on
and show you guys once we're through
with this graffiti list
[Music]
a b k what is up hey thanks for the
super chat lighting is everything agreed
william foshea showing awesome ue5
lighting guide that is yup i learned so
much from that
he is the man the master
definitely check out william foshay
if you guys uh
if you guys got a chance
yeah he's the one
i learned so much from his lighting
guide
[Music]
but it's true lighting is
so much of it
sweet
it's looking pretty darn good
we can get some tags on the pillars too
[Music]
now as far as animation goes that was
like the thing i basically ran out of
time to do yesterday so i did uh some
rain i started messing with some some
rain and some drip drops
coming from the top here and i can add
that real quick at the end and show you
guys it is a paid plug-in it's called
ultra dynamic sky i think is the name of
it and it was the first time i used it
yesterday it was really cool though and
i can't wait to get more into it
but
it is uh
quite a powerful advanced plug-in
and really easy to get some cool stuff
with so i'll show you guys that right at
the end now here's some leakage
some
grungy leakage
right you can kind of see get the idea
now it is obviously baked into my
concrete texture here
so we don't
really need it too much but
it is there to give you guys kind of an
idea
of what that looks like
with and without
[Music]
um
let's see
old book why do i have an old book
huh
that's actually kind of cool
like a poster or something
[Music]
but i don't know
it is a little random
that is a little random i
may just
put this thing
on the ground over here maybe
yeah it's fine
it's fine um
i think we're looking
pretty good graffiti-wise
i mean maybe we can get a couple more up
the wall
we can maybe duplicate one of these guys
that
you like this one we're not really
seeing this one too much
that's not half bad i mean
i guess the idea across
um
path tracing sure
pretty nuts
[Music]
so this is like the unbiased renderer
inside of
unreal engine which you can access
all of its settings in the post process
so if we type path trace
we can up the max bounces the samples
all this stuff we can get into the the
denoiser
we can try like 500
samples
and then the denoiser should kick in at
some point
yeah
pretty nuts
that looks really good
wow
i think it like it doesn't account for
fog actually
unfortunately it doesn't account for fog
but isn't that crazy this looks like uh
some ai art
just with the denoiser you know
yeah it's awesome how quick
unreal is
pretty sweet
but
we are gonna be
in this mode
lit mode all right what else y'all what
else we have a couple more things that
we can do
before we
render this thing and i'll get i'll talk
you through
render settings and whatnot um
the seam up here is looking a little
basic uh let me at least try
moving this to a point where
there is some sort of seam
yeah it's a little bit better
we can make the ceiling a little darker
as well
um so we can click the asset hit ctrl b
it's going to navigate to it in your in
your uh
content browser which i have on the
other screen here
[Music]
so this is our roof
um
and the roof has get rid of that there
we go uh in the details panel you can
navigate within this little folder with
the magnifying glass
to the material
and if we open up the material
instance right we can adjust
the brightness
like 0.5 or something
that way the focus is just a little bit
more on
our scene than the ceiling is a little
bright
awesome
um let's mess with
let's actually get rid of these streaks
i'm going to blow these out
so let's go to our rectangular light
i'm gonna hold
alt to duplicate it
control back tick
yep to get us to there you go
and i'll adjust the
attenuation radius so it's just focused
on
just right up in there
i'll get as close as i can
continuation radius
just enough so it blows that out
so we're not really seeing those streaks
and we can crank the color correction as
well to kind of hide that um what else
that's because my normals are bad
um let's go to the post process volume
and hit saturation we can get a little
bit of that global saturation
yeah that's nice let's
i want it to be a little bit more green
so we can go to our color correction or
our color grading rather go global gamma
and
just a little bit more like that it
feels
that feels nice to me
in our camera
let's adjust our depth of field so
currently our aperture is 2.8 we can set
it to like 1.2
to really blur out the foreground and
then we can
tell it to always track something so
focus method we set the track
and we'll choose what to track
so
probably just the
probably the latter so we can eye drop
the ladder that way the ladder is always
in focus no matter where we move
there was a really cool um like camera
distortion i actually you know what
do you does anyone know how to do camera
distortion
in unreal i i followed the tutorial
yesterday i built out like a
post-processed material
it worked but it
wouldn't render my scene in movie queue
so
i don't know if you guys
know of a method
um
what else can we do oh we can add a
little bit of greenery to this so
let me
switch to foliage mode
and
let's bring up our content browser we'll
dock it
[Music]
boom
and let's go to grass walled
let's get their volume 2 or now the
forest pack
and let's
pull one of these leaves which one which
one do we want
glycoma yes that's what we want
this leaf
leaf's got some crazy names all right
we'll drag it in
we'll make sure we navigate to it
camera's down again let me
reset
for y'all
boom boom
all right we got some leaves up in here
that's nice i like that
um i'm gonna make them a little bit
smaller
cool we got a patch
of greenery here
we can up the density as well
and we can kind of scatter some stuff
along the water
just for a little bit more detail also i
want to try one thing
so there's a material
in qixel bridge that is like a really
cool
wet
swamp
i think it is
mossy swamp ground
no
[Music]
swamp water
yeah these two these two i want to try
these real quick
because maybe it can give us a cool look
um
so we'll download these
come on now that's a slow download i
chill i chose highest quality that's
that's why you don't do that
do i recommend remaking uh
photographs i guess is what you're
trying to say is it good practice yes
and i love remaking my own photographs
that way i can say this is my art
that's the best part it's a cheat
you go out you take some photography you
recreate it in unreal post it up
and it's yours it's not some other
person's photo and then
you know
yeah it's it's actually really nice
so let's do
let's try um
where are you at i'm starting to lose my
mind here because we're towards the end
of the stream how long we have we gone
for
two hours two and a half hours
not bad
um materials no mega scans
surfaces
swamp water
let's apply it to this floor
and see
what that looks like
heck yeah
it's too big so i'll double click it
tiling and offset let's uh
tile it like
three times
that looks great
wow
that's super cool
and we can
tile it every which way we want
to get the most detail
that's wonderful so that's an option
okay i think that's way better
than what we had before
heck yeah that looks so good and then we
have this other swamp water which i
think is just not as green
but i love
oh that looks awesome
let's try it though
boom
[Music]
yeah
not as cool but it's
you know it works
it certainly works
i kind of like the other one better
though but i had three oh bossy swamp
ground
see what it looks like
oh that's nice
let's tile it
three times
that's the good stuff that
that's
i like that a lot
that looks freaking awesome
[Music]
heck yeah
i think that's about it i'm gonna take
my sun
directional light
and
let's give it a little bit more of a
source angle like five
oh man but we get that chunk
yeah i don't know why it's doing that
i mean what if we just took the sun out
and we
cranked no we need the sun we need a
little bit of the sun
take it to like 10 or something
five
and then we take the
skylight
and we boost the intensity of the
skylight to like three that'll give us
more of an ambient
kind of thing here and we take the
directional light again and maybe now
with the directional light and a more
chill yes
it pretty much works
heck yeah
and then we can take
our let's see
there's still a little bit of chunkage
on the left there some artifacting
but that's when we could bring our
post-process volume up
the vignette
just a little bit more to kind of mask
it a touch
and i think when we render this it'll
actually
hopefully will probably look a little
bit better
let's go to that directional light again
let's take that softness down to 10.
a little bit better okay we can take our
erect light two
and bring it up a little bit more
and have it maybe be like 100 by 100
[Music]
and increase the intensity
nah one looks better
directional light intensity
[Music]
that's not bad we can take our skylight
bring up the
general lift of the scene
that is not too shabby
sweet
now there is this nonsense up here
[Music]
going on i wonder if i can
really scoot these flags
in
as much as possible
to help
with that
[Music]
uh
it's a tough one
this is a tough one indeed
the vignette might be a little intense
[Music]
and i just want to test out this other
swamp water one more time
yeah that's i think that's better though
because it's just
we're getting more
reflections we were at
this before
but i really think
this
is better
and we can even crank
see the
base specular we can crank it to one
so it's a little bit brighter
roughness
i mean
zero
point two
yeah that's not bad at all
sweet
i think we're good to render this thing
so
let us
i need to expand this
oh these these are a little intense
because i can see them you're not
supposed to see them
heck yeah all right so to render this
out oh
rain okay we talked about rain
this is the
first time well technically i use my
concrete materials those are
a little bit but
uh this is called ultra dynamic sky it
is a paid plug-in on the uh
the marketplace
you can get to it by going here going to
marketplace this is the epic games
launcher we can look for
ultra dynamic
sky i think it's like 60 bucks
uh
why it doesn't not say the price but
it's super cool
and i was just discovering it yesterday
so here is what you can do in two
seconds
so
what you're gonna
do
is first off organize my scene
decals and geometry awesome
so i think ultra dynamic sky
let's get rid of all of our light except
our rectangular lights
and let's
drag in under blueprints
we can drag in the ultra dynamic sky
boom
it should do its thing
and what does it look like
looking like this right now
but we can like
control everything from we control fog
cloud coverage
right like you can get some
really cool
looks here
with this thing um overall intensity
what if we set that to like three
i don't know if that does anything
it's like a
brightness or something
anyway
what i'm doing with this
is
using the dynamic weather so if i drop
drop yeah
drag this in
you can see that we have rain
now
technically it shouldn't be raining
inside but
we can have
little drippy drops
coming from the ceiling right because it
is wet in here this is a well
so that's a good way to animate your
scene you can animate it a number of
other ways camera wise you can add rain
like this
um we can go to
the weather system
and
we can take
uh under
rain
you know we have more rain we have less
rain
really coming down
um
and we want it to be doing its little
drip drops
inside here so it's going on the roof
i take this roof
and i say be gone
should drip drop into our scene and have
some little splashes but this is perfect
because it's all coming from the opening
which is kind of what i want
anyway
and if i take that weather
and i crank it up to like
50 000
we can actually have it raining
from that little opening
up there which is awesome
but we need ambient light so
there's probably a million ways to do
this i'm just going to grab a rectangle
light
let's grab one of the ones already in
our scene
we can do this one
ctrl drag duplicate
flip it upside down so it's
pointing at the
ceiling
[Music]
you bring it right into the middle of
our scene
bring it up here
and if we
make it pretty darn large
depending on the angle you're at you can
uh
bounce some light off the ceiling this
is probably not the best way to do this
to be honest
yeah this is this is
probably not the way to go if i flip it
bring it up
and turn it off
turn it back on
we just need a little bit
to lift our scene
and that's already too much
so that's off
0.1 is still too much 0.05 maybe
0.02
just a little bit so that's with the
ultra dynamic sky there's probably a way
to like
lift the um
the ambient light in the scene because
we don't we can't really use our
directional light
but for the sake of rendering this thing
out i'm going to turn off this guy
and we're going to bring back
our original
light setup
so let's talk about render settings
[Music]
what you want to do for the best render
settings we will go to settings we will
go to plugins and you guys go to enable
movie
render queue
bam the movie render queue you'll
restart your engine and
what we want to do is set up a sequence
so that unreal knows
there are
frames to be exported all right so
i made a sequences folder
this is my level sequence
but you can make one by right clicking
go to animation level sequence you'll
create a level sequence
and i'll create one of these for you
and oh actually
this is where i want my content browser
to be
[Music]
there we go
so in your sequencer
you can
essentially choose your frame rate so
30fps
it's good if you want to do for film
more of that filmic look 24 is the way
to go
and you will drag your camera
i'm just gonna make a new one
level sequence
we're going to drag our camera in here
boom
and from here you can animate the camera
you can tell me how to tell how many
frames you want it to to be
so we can take this out to like 500 or
something
stretch this out
you got all your frames here
you can do a sweet camera move by
uh working the transform
location so we can do a sweet dolly
um we could do a dolly back
could be awesome
right so you would just
essentially come here you would make a
keyframe
go to another point in time come back
make a keyframe and when you hit play
bam
you have a nice little
animation
from that point you can animate your
lights too et cetera et cetera basically
anything with a little key key frameable
option you can animate
and we will go to this little clapboard
and the ellipsis next to it will allow
you to choose movie render queue and
until you enable that plugin you can't
do it
in here right we'll go to our settings
boom
and i have these pre-loaded console
variables
they're pinned in a comment
on the
forest
door render that i did two weeks ago
and basically i'll export a exr sequence
dwaa compression
um
anti-aliasing this one probably doesn't
need it depends on what you're doing if
you have motion blur or
plants that are blowing in the wind
you can add anti-aliasing and it really
helps smooth it out but remember it's
gonna
render 64
versions of one frame for every frame so
you're multiplying your render time by
64 essentially uh you can probably get
away with like 12 or something but
for this we don't really need it because
it's
it just depends on what you're doing if
there's movement if there's motion blur
etc anti-aliasing helps smooth those
things out
console variables this stuff is uh
what's pinned in the comment of my last
video
and
screen percentage is a great one that
will double the size of my output which
i currently have set to 4k it will
render an 8k image and scale it down to
fit in that 4k
uh resolution so it's a good way to
pack more detail into uh
your original file um
your resolution rather
and finally yeah you can override uh
your frame rate for 24 fps if you want
you can
shoot by default it'll render the amount
of frames you preset in your sequencer
or you can use a custom playback range
and only do like up to frame 10 whatever
and it will render your scene so
you know with a little bit more time
and tweaking
we spend a couple days on this
so this is what we just made today
um let's see
what we can do here uh
compare this to what i made yesterday
right so very very similar
very like darn similar
and that's probably with just a couple
more hours of work
and with an after effects pass where i
made a little had a little bit of lens
distortion
right but it is not far off
from what we just made here today
so that uh
that was freaking great
i i will take any time here let's turn
this camera on and see if this thing
works
oh boy
oh
we don't did it
now we're back
so that was that was a
how long it takes like three hours but
we did it though hopefully you guys
learned a thing or two
i know i sure did
i freaking love doing these scenes they
are the best
um if you guys have any questions i am
happy to answer
any questions you all have here
and we're gonna do the
weekly challenge
winner review here maybe after a little
bit of q a
but i need water
um
while you guys ask some questions so
let me have it
do a little app punisher for me so i can
see
y'all are asking questions yeah
wondrous
good question
what would your advice be to someone who
just had a 3d video go viral
my video got 19 million views in a month
and i don't know how to handle it
yeah um
that's a thing so i remember when i made
cardboard warfare
i was
i think i was just out of high school
and into college
and i was playing magic gathering at a
card shop
and cardboard warfare it got picked up
on
g4 attack of the show
and it you know they did a whole segment
on it it was like number one and i got a
million views
after that it like i couldn't focus on
magic the gathering anymore
it blew my mind
and that that moment for me at least
i was like wow
i can do this as a living now
um
i can see how people enjoy what i what i
love making so why don't i just keep
making the stuff i enjoy that was the
moment for me where i was like this can
be a thing
um
so that's the positive version of it the
more stressful anxious version of it is
like
you know you put out your first
video and it goes viral and you get a
bunch of views and you have this feeling
to
keep it up
and you have this feeling to
um
you know keep putting out content of
that
caliber
so that you can get back to that feeling
of
putting out a viral video it feels
stressful because like oh crap now i
have to post so much and i have to do so
much
i would say
let it be
an inspiration to you
and a
a sign to you
that
you're making good stuff
if you had fun making that viral video
um keep
having fun doing what you love
not everyone will be viral i promise
that
um
it is a luck thing
but it's also a preparedness thing if
you are prepared
and you're staying well oiled and you
are doing your 3d art and you're loving
it and you're posting and you're showing
it
one of them will catch on like they did
um
i'd say my other thing too is like
have a place
if you can
have a home base where if it goes viral
it goes viral from your home base
um because when we did boss town
dynamics at corridor we posted the first
one it got reposted all over the
internet it got ripped a million times
and it probably wouldn't have done as
well as if if it did not get ripped like
that
but i think at the time corridor
they either like
didn't have
a facebook
an official facebook post
or they didn't have an official like
twitter post or something
because like it got like 34 million
views from some twitter post
and some other facebook posts got like
19 million as well and in the best case
scenario it's your original video that's
being shared like that as opposed to a
reshare
um so that would be another piece of
advice it's like make sure that
you have a house
for
your
3d art your content your videos your
whatever to
blast out from
um so
yeah you just don't want people ripping
off your your video posting it on their
facebook and getting a million views
from it you can't really do anything
about that
so that
is very stressful
yeah that's very stressful
um
hopefully they're giving credit at least
they're giving credit and pointing to to
the original that's what you want
um
l
how would you go about adding the
dripping effect uh we did the dripping
effect with the ultra dynamic sky
and the weather system
sky what's up hey do you uh are you
interested in making stylized scenes in
ue for the next live stream i would love
to i just don't know how to
um but i love that like breath of the
wild style
uh big fan of that
have you ever tried exr workflow with
movie or in the queue yeah all the time
i always do exr xr's out of movie render
q bring it into davinci bring it into
after effects depending
um
what else do we got mitch mitch hey man
what's up
final result looks great any performance
tips for running ue on lower end
machines yes so
i believe nanite you know if you're
taking stuff uh from qixel you can
export it as nanite if you're importing
your own stuff make sure you check the
nanite build nanite mesh box
that's gonna make things a lot faster
and easier for you
what else uh
optimization i'm not the biggest
like i don't have the most
tips on optimization what else
um
okay
yeah here's the thing on the top left
you should see like a scalability option
and it's mine set to cinematic you can
set it down you can like lower
the scalability
um
let me just show you really quick
so
right here on the left we have it's set
to cinematic it's the highest it's maxed
out
you can set it to epic
it'll you know
looks pretty darn similar
but now you notice it's gone right so if
you go to settings
engine scalability settings that's where
it's at okay
um
you can take it down to low if you want
i had to do this when i was painting
foliage
lod zero foliage
on my last scene
and guaranteed you're gonna be
navigating just fine this way
you can drop the exposure
right
and then when you go to render
you switch over to cinematic
right
so that's
probably the biggest thing also you
don't need 8k textures
right bring in the lower res textures
you can switch them out later if need be
what else what else
what do we got um i'm just going down
the ones where that you've you've added
me here nexib
um
you've been trying out mixer to create
variation
with quick glasses i i have not tried it
out yet but i need to
certainly
ah ahmad how do i get my idea it's based
off of a photo i took in this
water well thing
in newfoundland i climbed down into it
because i'm just like that i love
me some uh urban exploration so
naturally i find myself
at the bottom of a sewer
uh and taking shots you know
not alcoholic shots
photography all
um
and then i use that i use my own
photography as my reference to create 3d
scenes with
jason have you been using 3d scans more
um
yes actually so
in two weeks from now my god is it
really two weeks from now
i hadn't even
i gotta kick it up a notch
because i'm putting out a video that
hasn't started yet
but i'm putting out a video on how to
do massive scale scans with a drone how
to capture mountains and stuff
so
i'm gonna be piecing that together it's
coming out in i believe in two weeks
look out for it it's gonna be awesome
yeah i love me some 3d scans bring those
in as nanite meshes and your stuff is
looking good
um
can i do a tutorial on niagara fluids i
don't know how to do that so
well maybe when i figure it out
absolutely
how do i find lost places like this
abandoned places i look them up online
i think there's a place called urbex.com
it's like urban exploration
and it's always out of date it's very
old but you can find stuff that way but
i'll always look for abandoned places if
i'm if i'm visiting a place or i'll pull
off on the side of the road and just
explore
um will z myth will smith when is the
next big challenge it is sooner than you
all think
so another reason if you are not
subscribed and you want to participate
in one of these awesome 3d challenges
hit that subscribe button hit that dang
bill you guys know how this works
because
in a very short amount of time
we're going to be getting together for
the next 3d community challenge
i'm recording the mocap on monday
with a very
very cool person
so
yeah get excited it's gonna be sweet
what else um
yeah that's that's about it
bought it all right y'all i'm gonna do a
little uh weekly challenge
break down here and i'll come back if
you guys got any more questions but
we're gonna talk about the weekly
challenge the theme this week
was wild west so let's switch on over
and do some art review shall we
community art review
all right
let me full screen this discord view
here
okay
so like i said
we are
talking about the weekly challenge wild
west was the theme
we got five winners to get into each of
which will get 15 points to their rank
on the server which is a nice little
emblem
connected to your name on the discord
server the link is below if you guys
want to join the disk discord server
this is all free the weekly challenge is
free
i do have a patreon
that's also in the description
and um you just get access to the pro
lounge where we'll do game nights
sometimes
um hang out together you guys can vote
on the weekly challenge as well and
determine what the weekly challenge is
so it's a cool way to get involved a
little bit um but let's hop into these
winners first and foremost
we have
john malcolm
with this beautiful
render right here um absolutely
fantastic
the lighting is fantastic you modeled
this pistol yourself that is the most
impressive thing if it was an asset
oh
maybe had to have been an honorable
mention but the fact that you modeled
all of this you you sculpted those
glasses too
i love
that you actually used um ai art
i think it was mid journey to create the
design on
the cards
and then you took that and i don't know
if you took it further or if it
literally were like an ai art you
probably cleaned it up but i think it's
a great way to use it it's a small thing
it's not the entire thing but you're
incorporating it incorporating that in a
really cool way um but congratulations
to you john malcolm this is a great
piece very well lit very well
uh modeled
and presented
very good stuff man next up who do we
got
oh
oh man
good stuff
all good all good sodamonte apologizes
for the ears
um
let's see yeah let's watch that again
it's super cool this is all unreal
engine
this is the sci-fi
sci-fi west i love it so good
perfect camera shake
beautiful explosion really nice fire you
got going great detail you got the cape
moving this is freaking awesome metatrox
congratulations for winning this week's
weekly challenge 15 points to you
and you get that pro tier access too you
get that lounge for a week
good times
who is next
bam obliviart
freaking
awesome
so so good i love this lighting as
creepy as all um
the composition is cool this is also
unreal engine
yeah man you're killing it my one note
for you is to take the
uh
the arm of that creature and get it up
onto the building because it looks like
this creature just has one arm
and you want to give it a bit more
clarity so i'd have that arm up
with this hooks around the side of the
steeple of that thing like that would be
so cool
otherwise it just looks like a one-armed
creature um but man you crushed it with
your lighting and your design and you
modeled that thing from scratch so
congratulations
for winning this week's challenge who's
next we got skye
yes so this is a re-creation
um
you recreated another artist's work
which we cannot show on the stream
um because i think the original is a
little bit more revealing
um
but you did a fantastic job
with this scene here um
it's a perfect recreation
it's very beautiful it's very well lit
it's very well modeled colored
everything
you did a really solid job and you gave
the character a little bit more of a
cartoony look to them which i really dig
so congratulations skye you're doing
great stuff
and finally the last winner we're gonna
get into the honorable mentions all
right but the last winner
is
visual our very own visual
yes
killing it with these dads characters
man
doing great work i love this so much
detail your lighting's perfect your
composition is fantastic
it's a beautiful scene i love them
glasses dude i gotta give me some of
them glasses
heck yeah so congratulations to all the
winners and since one of our moderators
won they already have access to all the
stuff on the server they're mods um so
they they will give their
um challenge winner roll out to one of
these honorable mentions that we're
gonna get into um so
i feel it's a little bit more fair that
way
um
and the honorable mentions each get five
points to their role so y'all keep
ranking up
all right we got a bunch of cool tiers
on the discord server
so first up honorable mention we got 3d
gala
popping off i thought this was a
fantastic idea
i don't know if this was a reference
from somewhere but
it's freaking cool
um it's just a good idea obviously it's
violent yes it's violent
but it's a fantastic idea i would love a
little bit more light it's hard to tell
kind of what is going on i had to take a
second look at it
um especially on the right side of frame
uh i think a top-down like tarantino
style top-down light
blasting onto that table
maybe maybe the way to go i mean it's
not bad certainly it's not bad and your
render quality is fantastic so
good stuff uh next up honorable mention
we have danelle daniel
um
yeah beautifully lit
i love the angle
tells the story of what's going on it's
gonna be a little uh
we got some cowboys coming in here to
rough up whoever
is in this saloon here and you got a
little hero character in the middle i
love that
your lighting is solid
that was my
biggest takeaway from this thing um
and i really dig the angle too
next up is
fabi phoebe
i don't know um
this one's great this one came close to
winning
uh i think your lighting is is the best
part and actually your composition is
not half bad either i would love to see
a little bit more backlight on that
cross
to tell what it is if i squint i should
be able to see what's going on
but your your lighting is really really
nice i do love the sky
the ground that you have going on there
um
note wise i would
give a bit more clarity to the character
it's hard to see what's going on it
looks like they are playing the violin
maybe
um i i would love to see more of an arm
more of a hand
holding a pistol the left hand you know
it's a little difficult to tell
silhouette wise i know that she has like
a jacket on that's kind of
you know
doing a thing but it just
it muddies up her silhouette to make it
a little bit hard to tell what's going
on
another thing too as i give the ground a
little bit more
detail smaller rocks smaller shrubs i
can tell you scattered the one plant
you needed a lot more
um
that would be my only note yeah those
are
anyway it's good stuff it's it's awesome
stuff um we have
ha ha ha
next up
i love this idea
it's a samurai cowboy i mean like what
else do i need to say
you framed it nicely you lit it nicely
i think it's a great design so congrats
lord cabbage is next
this is a freaking cool scene it's a
little dark
but that's kind of the point i like the
way it's lit i like the town it totally
reminds me of
elden ring there's like an area
that you go into in a valley and it has
all these like spirits that are just
blasting you with freaking spirit
spirit blasts the whole time
um
it totally reminds me of that but i love
it it's dark and moody
pretty sweet environment next up we have
ryujin
yeah i love this like i you know i've
seen these before
blender street has a lot of them on
their instagram
um
i i just like that it's actually sitting
in an environment
um and i've never really seen
a
saloon or i guess this is more of a
sheriff's office office in jail as it
says by the sign
i hadn't really seen that usually you
see people's offices or like bedrooms
done in that style so i thought this was
pretty sweet keep it up good stuff
the game factory is next dude you
knocked it out
with your decision here you said this
was originally
an animation
but since you ran out of time
you turn it into this little comic strip
and i think that's perfect man that's
such a good idea instead of
you know rushing something out that
wasn't complete you took what you had
and you made it complete
i love it i think it's very very smart
to change
halfway through or three quarters of the
way through and do what you did so i
think that's awesome
i think your scene's cool i think it's
well well lit it'd be nice to see a
little bit more
silhouette on that gun
i want to see the shape of that gun a
little bit more i think it's also a
little small i think
and then the one on the right
i feel like an edge light on the
character in the foreground could help
you
bring that out as well as an edge light
on the character being shot it's hard to
tell kind of what's going on but
you know i think it's awesome so
keep it up
next up um we have tinum
this one came very close to winning as
well
i really like the lighting
i dig the character that you made
i think it's awesome this is another one
that i think could benefit from a little
bit more of like a right arm coming out
just a little bit to catch that
silhouette
because you kind of lose the arm
on this character's leg here
but i mean other than that like this is
freaking solid like i said you came
really really really close to winning so
please keep it up
weekend is next
this is just well lit well composed like
what else can you say
the darkest point of the the darkest and
brightest point
of the image is your focal point which
is the character in the background
and
you also have this character in the
foreground
who is bright against the dark saloons
that really helps pop that character out
and it feels completely natural
it's beautiful great lighting
really nice scene very very simple
and finally the last honorable mention
is zeus creates
i thought this was a not too bad here
i thought the lighting was pretty good
i thought you did a good job of adding a
bunch of characters in giving them a
different uh different action different
pose that felt right
and of course the brightest and darkest
point
of the image is
your focal point the character coming
into the saloon
and with that y'all
we have successfully gotten through
another weekly challenge
i think
we
i
i haven't lost count but the count isn't
quite accurate we're almost at 100
weekly challenges
that might be way off
but according to my com
yeah 93
heck yeah
heck yeah
that's a lot
i've been doing this for
two years now maybe a little over two
years we've been doing weekly challenges
every single week and y'all been
crushing it so thank you so much
uh alwyn i see you thank you for that
super chat
my chance of failure is absolute zero i
appreciate that every time dude
heck yeah that's what's up so y'all that
is i mean that's it
um
i'm happy to answer any questions
y'all have i'll hang out with you for
another five or so
maybe play a little bit of
the native flute
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
that's a tough note it's a half note
[Music]
this thing's freaking great i love this
i got this from uh
blue blue bear flutes
i think
smells so good
god
but you know i do a lot of rock climbing
and
constantly find myself at the top of a
mountain
of just wind and quiet and i'm like why
do i not have a flute to play at the top
of a mountain so
that is why i got this i have yet to
play it on the top of a mountain
but i cannot wait
any news on the community challenge it's
coming soon y'all it is coming very very
soon
mega soon to render whatever is sacred
to you or whatever image or whatever
render communicates
sacred
nature i don't know
um
so you got you guys got a week you all
got a week
[Music]
alwyn hey i appreciate you man i
appreciate i don't know how loud this is
on the mic
but but god it's so much fun to play um
can i play some zelda i cannot play
zelda yet
but i think is this on it's like
there's something like that right i
forget exactly what zelda song is but
it's somewhere in there i'm definitely
definitely gonna
learn some of that because why not
um
how do you learn unreal like early on i
learned unreal by forcing myself to do a
project in unreal
and
um originally i had steve began reach
out to me i did a stream with steve
he was like hey man
i hear you're trying to learn unreal
because i'm doing these streams right
i'm like i want to learn unreal i want
to learn unreal you can watch my first
stream in unreal of me like failing and
figuring some stuff out it was i think
it's like a five hour stream but
steve reached out he's like man i'll
help you out and he met with me every
friday for like two or three hours and
kind of answered any questions i had
thank god for steve he oh that's why i
call him my unreal sensei because he
stepped up and he like
answered every question i had for
for a few months every friday for a few
hours
um from that point i was able to like
kind of get my bearings and you know i
figured out how materials work and kind
of figure out how lighting worked
there's a million different lights in
unreal makes it confusing it's easier
now in unreal five because everything's
kind of automatic
but um
i just had to take on a project and
that's why i love these little
environments is because i they're
contained
um
and they're doable you know it's not a
whole i can do it in a day
so it's super satisfying find a project
for you a small scale project that you
can complete
um
and and and that you have to complete
it's a good way to do it there's a video
i made it's uh a music video
and it's one of my earlier unreal engine
videos
it's a pre-edited video it's not a live
stream
and it's like
everything i learned in unreal engine in
the first like year and a half and that
is a video i made after i completed my
first full project on unreal going over
all the
all the things i learned that i would
have loved to know when i first started
so that's a good one
also the one i made last two weeks two
weeks ago that's a good one too
like the forest door scene
um what else
anything else on the monthly y'all want
that monthly
3d community challenge info it's coming
up y'all it is coming up very soon so be
ready we pretty much have the prizes
locked
we have the schedule locked
we have the template pretty much locked
we just need to execute it
um
yeah i mean we're hoping these are
bigger and better every single time so
just get excited
steve begin not steve bacon vegan it's
going to be steve
beagan
i believe
yeah
um
do you think you'll cover the modeling
or asset production in a new e5
doom
thanks for making the stream i saw this
was your first one
uh that you could follow along with
cover modeling your asset product i i
don't really model an unreal
i'll model in c4d
um but i'm starting to get
not used to i'm starting to
get familiar with unreal's modeling
tools
or asset production uh what do you mean
asset production like making my own
photo scans
i got videos on that if that's what you
mean but
yeah i don't know i mean it depends on
what i use for a project if i create a
piece of art
depends on like the tools i use for that
art i'll talk about it yeah
um
capoxo have i been drawing lately i have
not
i've mostly been rock climbing
playing the flute
um
making 3d art
very busy very very busy
yeah i've been busy
trying to build out the schedule for the
weekly chat or the community challenge
coming up
um
and trying to
take time to myself
but
yeah
it's been good
what are my thoughts on otoy's version
of nanite called meshlitz in c14
meshlets that sounds funny i don't know
anything about meshlets
i knew that they were trying to do
brigade which was their like real-time
thing
um
i don't know anything about mesh lips
i'll have to look it up that is good to
know i appreciate that
uh funk
molly
my sincere thanks to you for sharing and
teaching your knowledge for future
artists from all over the world please
never stop what you're doing big love
thank you very very much i appreciate
that
and uh you know i do what i can i enjoy
creating stuff and i know it's difficult
to create things and i know a lot of
people want to create things so why not
give a little insight into the process
but you know i can't promise i'll be
doing it forever and ever
who knows i know i know i'm gonna be
making a movie
pretty soon here um
and when i'm off making this movie
i will not be able to live stream i will
not be able to
post
pre-edited videos on vfx
but that doesn't mean i'm just gonna
not be here so i'm trying to figure out
what the plan would be and i'll probably
do some pulse stuff and figure out like
what you guys are looking for but the
most like no-brainer thing for me is to
like
while i'm on set while i'm shooting
have someone there who can shoot and
also edit some like behind the scenes
educational uh interview
type stuff
while the movie is being filmed
um so
that's the that's the like basic plan as
of now but
you know we'll get there when the time
comes
hopefully
sometime next year
what else y'all what else how's the wife
wife is good she's out with her friends
right now
arthur what's up hello from brazil
i mean that's about it y'all
that is about it
thank you guys so much for hanging out
with me for checking out the art
um
it's been a good time it's been a very
good time
so uh two weeks from now
look out for a aerial photogrammetry
video
i'm gonna be climbing to the top of a
mountain with my buddy jan
we're gonna post up early in the morning
when i get there at like 5 a.m
and we're going to set up set up base
we're going to send the drone out on
these missions
they're going to i'm going to you know
do a bunch of scans of mountains
large scale stuff huge stuff
and come back
to home base
and
walk you through the process of how to
stitch it all together
use it in your art
right so that's gonna be uh two weeks
from now
so wish me luck i
voyage on
on tuesday is when i
when i ship off
climb these these mountains it's gonna
be sweet i'm bringing the flute of
course i'm gonna bring the flute
peter short is out
scooty's out
shoot no i have not seen it yet but
thanks for the heads up
that's awesome
i think that's it everybody um soto do
you want to queue up the music for this
art i'll switch over to it and i'll just
uh
where's that the ending screen
i believe it's the ending screen right
anyway i'll see you i'll see y'all
i'll see you all soon
good times good vibes always
and uh keep creating
see y'all peace
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
you